before this covet thing you and Brad had
some good conversations I would say
we're friends what's your what do you
admire most about Brett outside of all
the criticism we've had about this kova
topic
well I think Brett is very smart and
he's a very um ethical person who wants
good things for the world I mean I have
no reason to doubt that so the fact that
we're on you know we're cross-wise on
this issue is not does not mean that I
think he's
a bad person I mean the thing that
worried me about what he was doing
and this was true of Joe and this was
true of Elon this is true of many other
people is that once you're messaging at
scale
to a vast audience
you incur a certain kind of
responsibility not to to get people
killed and I do I did worry that
yeah people were people were making
decisions on the basis of the
information that was getting shared
there and that that's why I was
I think fairly circumspect I just said
okay give me the the
center of the Fairway expert opinion at
this time point and at this time point
at this time point
and then I'm out right I don't have any
more to say about this I'm not an expert
on covet I'm not an expert on it the
safety of mRNA vaccines
um
if something if something changes so as
to become newsworthy then maybe I'll do
a podcast so I mean I just did a podcast
on collably right like I was never
skeptical of the lab Lake hypothesis
Brett was very early on saying this is
this is a lab leak right
um at a point where my only position was
who cares if it's a lab leak right like
this there's the thing we have to get
straight is what do we do given the
nature of this pandemic but also we
should say that you've actually stated
that it is a possibility oh yeah you
just said it doesn't doesn't it I mean
it the time to figure that out now I've
actually I've had my my podcast guest on
this topic changed my view of this
because you know one of the guests uh
Elena Chan made the point that you know
actually the the best time to figure out
the origin of this is immediately right
because in the Abbott you lose touch
with the evidence and I hadn't really
been thinking about that like I didn't
if you come back after a year
um
you know there are certain facts you
might not be able to get in hand but
I've always felt that it didn't matter
for two reasons one is
we had the Genome of the virus and and
we could design we're very quickly
designed immediately designing vaccines
against that genome and that's what we
had to do and then we had to figure out
how to vaccinate and to
and to mitigate and to develop
treatments and all that
so the origin story didn't matter
generically speaking
either or origin story was
politically inflammatory and made the
Chinese look bad right and the Chinese
response to this looked bad whatever the
origin story right they're not
cooperating they're letting they're
stopping their domestic flights but
letting their international flights go I
mean it's just they were bad actors and
they should be treated as such
regardless of the origin right and you
know I would argue that the wet Market
origin is even more politically
invidious than the lab League origin I
mean why do you think because for lab
leak to my eye
the lab leak could happen to anyone
right we're all running all these
Advanced countries are running these
dangerous labs
as a practice that we should be worried
about you know in general
we know lab leaks are a problem there
have been multiple lab leaks of even
worse things that haven't gotten out of
hand in this way but you know worse
pathogens
um
we're
we're wise to be worried about this and
on some level it could happen to anyone
right the wet Market makes them look
like barbarians live in another Century
like you got to clean up those wet
markets like what are you what are you
doing putting a bat on top of a Pangolin
on top of a duck it's like get your
together so like if anything
the wet Market makes them look worse in
my view now I'm sure there's I'm sure
that what they actually did to conceal a
lab leak if it was a lab leak all of
that's going to look odious
um do you think we'll ever get to the
bottom of that I mean one of the big
negative
um I would say failures of Anthony fauci
and so on is to be transparent and clear
and it's just a good communicator about
gain and functional research the dangers
of that the success like the you know
why it's a useful way of research but
it's also dangerous right you know just
being transparent about that as opposed
to just coming off really shady of
course the conspiracy theorists and the
the politicians are not helping but this
just created a
giant mess yeah no I would agree that so
that exchange with fauci and Rand Paul
that went viral yeah I would agree that
fauci looked like he was
taking refuge in kind of very lawyered
language
and not
giving a straightforward account of what
we do and why we do it and so yeah I
think it looked Shady it played shady
and it probably was shady I mean I don't
know how personally entangled he is with
any of this but
yeah the gain of function research is
something that
I think we're wise to be worried about
and insofar as I judge myself adequate
to have an opinion on this
I think it should be banned right like I
I I'm probably a podcast I'll do you
know if you or somebody else doesn't do
it in the meantime
um
you know I I would like a virologist on
to defend it against a virologist who
who who would uh criticize it forget
about the gain a function research
I don't even understand virus hunting at
this point it's like I don't know I
don't even know why you need to go into
a cave to find this next virus that
could be circulating among bats that
made jump zoonotically to us
why do that when we can make when we
when we can sequence in a day and and
make vaccines in a weekend I mean like
like what kind of Head Start do you
think you're getting that's a surprising
new thing how quickly can develop a
vaccine exactly that's uh
yeah that's that's really interesting
but the shadiness around lab League
I think the point I didn't make about
Brett's style of engage in this issue is
people are using the fact that he was
early on Lab Lake
to suggest that he was right about
Ivermectin and about mRNA vaccines and
all the rest like no that that's
none of that connects and it was
possible to be falsely confident like
you shouldn't have been confident about
lab no one should have been confident
about lab leak early even if it turns
out to be lap league right it was always
plausible it was never definite it still
isn't definite zoonotic is is is also
quite plausible it certainly was super
plausible then
um both are politically
uncomfortable uh both were both at the
time were inflammatory to be banging on
about when we were trying to secure some
kind of cooperation from the Chinese
right so there's a time for these things
and and
and it's possible to be right by
accident right that's the that is it
it Matt you're you're reasoning the
style of reasoning matters whether
you're right or not
you know it's like because your style of
reasoning is dictating what you're going
to do on the next topic